false information out loud so there is
validity in doing that
uh i think we we have gabe joining us
gabe how are you hey what's up how are
you fine i got your stuff yeah it's
getting a little better i'm exercising
it okay do i sound people thought i
sound like lego batman you
[Applause]
do i should i i thought i sounded like
alex joe alex jones this is my house
you're a bit on the alex jones side i
would say so it's like
it's like lego batman and alex jones
combined
okay can you uh can you share your
screen
and uh
and maybe talk about some stuff for just
a few minutes
i've had to drink a lot of water yeah
this morning yeah yeah i gotta
give me
one go ahead and go ahead and take see
if and and see if you can take over the
shitless round up here just
a few minutes
i'm uh i'm drowning over here in water
oh yeah
all right all right all right uh so that
means i got to go on to twitter now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
i'm just crazy yeah you're gonna
actually have to take controls here all
right let me go to a break and then when
we come back yeah let's do that i mean
do you want to keep talking about
shitless stuff yeah go ahead go ahead go
ahead and find go through the trends
yeah find the trend that you want to
talk about you know how to share this
works yeah yeah yeah we were just
talking about the russian bank thing